she's waiting for you today was the
first time we got to do real like cool
sort of demony stuff right there hold
move not too crazy but just the start of
it so it's really
exciting when I'm assembling a team for
a project like this I obviously want
someone talented and I need people that
are skilled I need people that are fast
and I need people that understand the
design ethic that I want I very bad at
like being
patient tired very tired busting your
chops what I want to drink I have to
have a straw but it's not that tricky
Dick Smith's The Godfather of makeup
effects man and not only the Godfather
of makeup effects but the Godfather of
The
Exorcist there's a lot of moving parts
to this makeup a lot of pieces to it a
lot of things you have to get right with
doing the hair and the tape and this in
order for this to go down right so it
doesn't buck it's a lot of mechanics to
it the question everybody's always
asking me it's like do you think Dick
Smith would be proud what do you think
Dick Smith would say about your makeups
what do you think and I go don't ask me
that